so hi I'm Alyssa thread by day I run the
MIT k12 videos program in the office of
digital learning at MIT and I was the
lead instructor / creator for 22 19 hi
I'm Joshua gun and I'm the founder co
founder of Planet nutshell a cambridge
massachusetts-based animation studio and
my role in the course was simply to do a
workshop on storyboarding as well as a
little instruction on animation in the
context of producing educational media
my name is George Zaidan I am a
freelance science video host and writer
and producer and for 22 19 I did a
workshop on writing and hosting I'm
Chris Babel I'm mediate development
director for MIT s office of digital
learning and for the course site was
basically a guest lecturer I came in for
a day or two to talk about visual
storytelling so the way this class
started I would say is George and I were
working on science out loud which is
this educational web series that's
hosted by MIT students and sort of
noticed that there was this big need to
help students not only know how to
articulate themselves on camera
articulate well on camera but just
understand digital media in general and
that's a conversation that Chris and I
have had since since I was your student
that's an undergrad basic thing yeah
yeah so yeah actually not really but
yeah with science out loud I mean we we
would do these like crash courses on
scripting and writing these short videos
but at the end of the day like we would
still intervene quite a bit to make the
videos good and at the end of the day
the priority was making a great video
and not necessarily on the students
learning experience so I mean this was a
space for them to develop these skills
sort of lower stakes you know and not
have to worry about creating something
that was like going to be on a web
series of the
the class was supposed to be lower
stakes yeah yeah because we had the
science out loud was a lot of pressure
we were shooting long days if they did
you know they were didn't I felt like if
they didn't get the take right they were
nervous yeah or like if the script just
wasn't good by the time we had to shoot
like we would just fix it you know yeah
and one of the things you and I have
talked about a ton over the last couple
of years is that tension between
creating a consistently good product and
teaching because if you're in a teaching
environment you know in ever you know
you're going to fail over and over and
over again which does not lead to a
particularly you know consistently good
product which is what you're going for
with science out loud so this class is
kind of a way I think to I find a space
in between where you can actually have
have a little bit of a chance to
experiment and learn by doing and fail
bluntly but also you know not actually
impact your show which is it needs to be
consistently good was there any desire
to sort of create an awareness for
students of like other sort of creative
opportunities outside of the science and
math are their current studies I mean
like I think it's a really interesting
way this course is sort of offered to
students who are engaged in stuff that's
really quite different yeah I mean it's
interesting because MIT has this
communication requirement it's not
really taken seriously by students
because it's it's like I need to take a
classroom required to write 20 pages of
the paper and you and I were talking
about one of the bio engineering
communication fellows and he said
something like I'm doing this program
because I don't see a difference between
science and science communication which
I really I think like that inadvertently
was what this class was about because
it's not really about like how to host a
science show or how to write a five
minute script like that i don't care if
they never make a five minute video
again but hopefully the skills that they
learned and picked up were things that
they need to have regardless of what
they
going into just the ability to
articulate passionately and clearly some
very technical topics is it not only
that you can get tricky you get trained
on enough at MIT yeah i think i think
the MIT communication requirement is an
interesting situation too because it is
all focused on writing and you know
writing papers not even just writing not
even writing like writing scripts
writing papers and for instance the
course that I teach that you took we
initially had trouble getting it listed
as is fulfilling the communication
requirement even though students
consistently said well this is all this
course is about you know communication
because the writing requirement was just
a little bit shy of the 20 page or
whatever it is a requirement so it's
there's a whole other kind of
communication which is as you say you
know clear clear conceptualization
visualization organization which is
related to writing and writing kind of
traditional papers but but you know it's
in 2015 it's not just writing journal
papers or kind of really more
traditional pieces of text actually
before I put the class together the
first thing I did was just survey all of
the media making classes on campus so
anything related to video production or
like script production and there are
actually a lot of classes on campus that
are about you know how do you edit how
do you produce video but there wasn't
one on really hosting actually and being
on camera and being comfortable talking
in front of people was something that we
found to be very important through
science out loud and something that
students were the most uncomfortable
with would you say yeah I mean they were
they didn't even know they were
uncomfortable with it they would just
get they'd be like I had no problem I
just I'll just talk and and then get in
front of a camera and it's like Jack
Donaghy in that episode of 30 rock
really like can't really can't you know
you don't understand why your body
doesn't quite work the way you thought
it was your voice is a little too high
and you get nervous and then you'd screw
up and then you screw up again and then
you know they get and then they then
they realize how hard it actually is to
stand in front of a camera and say
things so yeah just about standing in
front of a camera though like any
audience ready I feel like it was like I
wanted them to learn how to be self
aware of who they were as a presenter
you know because like we weren't trying
to make them become a persona like we
called it becoming the next bill nye but
it really wasn't that was like the first
thing I talked about was that we're not
actually turning you into Bill Nye that
wherever you go whether it's a job
interview or are you giving a TED talk
or formal presentation I mean you need
all these skills and you you can't like
assume some sort of platonic personality
you know when you do these things it's
not acting it's just being being
yourself themselves yeah mm-hmm but just
a clear polish oh yeah kind of close to
what the real thing is but maybe not
entirely there where it is yeah